hi this is pressure Locker in this video
will present the solutions to the three
different puzzles involving matchsticks
in the first puzzle
we had the shape of the fish and we
wanted to move three of the matches so
that the fish was looking in the other
direction or the fish was swimming to
the right so here's the solution here's
one matchstick that you move here's the
second one and finally here's the third
one
and the resulting configuration we have
the fish it's the same exact shape but
it's now looking the other way in the
second puzzle we had a cup which had ice
cubes inside of it
we wanted to make the ice cubes outside
of the cup so for this we're going to
move this stick slide it right over and
then we take the other stick and form a
cup so now the cup it's the same shaped
cup it's upside down now the ice is on
the outside of the cup
finally we have the mathematical
equation five plus seven equals two we
want it to move just one match to fix
this equation so here's the trick where
you move this one match from the plus
sign to make a nine so now we have nine
minus seven equals two and that's of
course correct I hope you liked this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions on Twitter at
pressure Locker and you can get my books
listed on my website